questi anni dopo avervi illustrato il
mio amore per la blizzard sono qui oggi
per annunciarmi la nuova espressione di
arthur espansione si chiama con lia alla
piena di luna cuba anche questa volta
abbiamo ben 85 bustine da gustare per
insomma colpire le nostre infoltire il
nostro mazzo di carte nuove e disgustare
ragazzi due novità che ha raggiunto per
le spiego così a meno se troviamo carte
del genere capite di cosa si tratta ci
sono le carte corruzione che se lei
nella mano si potenziano quando metti
una carta di mana del costo di mana più
alto ci sono delle carte leggendarie che
hanno aggiunto sugli degli antichi di
volta ci sono i manufatti degli antichi
e tra l'altro hanno aggiunto le imprese
se sono queste qua che praticamente il
gioco tiene traccia della progressione
dato retroattivo uniti conta anche le
cose che già hai fatto quindi vedete
quanto fatto schifo e per finire c'è la
modalità nuova e la modalità duelli e
una sorta di arena modificata dove devi
far crescere il tuo marzo è molto
interessante sembra è ancora in beta ma
la proveremo sicuramente il dopo aver
sfruttato le nostre carte nuove che
andiamo a sostare right now a ci sono 5
maxi d'oro 80 standard di prima da
scartare gli standard gianpi metti i
migliori carte che sposterà in questo
momento le scavo
coniglio di luna cupa 10 di di mana 11
ma dove ecco la zai l'incredibile copia
la carta più a sinistra e quella piu a
destra e ha dato a mano dai affacci di
oggi è natale ragazze ti prego che non
sia quella di prima perché a volte va
bene di ritrovarla il tool allora allora
allora faccio yoga l'ho trovata adorata
leggendaria che curò bilie tus quello
che c'hai sull'autobus
dai dai che battute dimetterà sua diet è
trovata la multa l'ultima figurina del
dell'ultimo pacchetto che perfetto
vediamo mastai anche calmo zio
archibugio di madonna che ansia sto
occhio nel cecchino bene lei allora
vediamo un attimo sera allora la mia
infestato secondo me è ok io andrei di
moneta non so se sbaglia a fare questa
roba perché effettivamente dovrà di
testarlo incombe però fa niente abbiamo
di ragni infestata l'udc è un cono
d'ombra in cina tra di saluto
personaggio se ancora danneggiato pesca
una carta ma quando un tuo servitore
viene attaccato evoca delle serpi questo
qua mi serve per prendere innanzitutto
buono signora userei e fa morano stato
questo assicura manetta quindi chi se ne
frega
dopo che lasciare la sua magia evoca un
felino con frutti vita ma io direi di no
io andrei di
borin e lubriano che mi permette di
avere un po di buono e poi infligge 2
danni e poi uno di attacco a un
servitore casuale mi servirebbe sulle
rubbiano questa cosa allora vado di
poter eroe
poi gli vado addosso con questo peccato
2.000 euro se fosse stato abbiamo
sentito meglio devo buttarmi il problema
delle rovine rubbiano come sempre è
dargli l'attacco per poi farlo esplodere
male però mi ha dato un attacco
all'altro quindi tutti i servitori conto
come le 5 superiore bella mossa ma non
abbastanza
prima facevo questo per il due anni è
l'eroe lì mica per niente perché magari
lo davano che culo perfetto di tenere
conto che santoro in forno ma comune che
tutto sia stato in the face
vediamo come va ragazzi non lo so e non
ancora detto però le serpi o questo qua
che mi evoca un altro secondo me non
sono insomma l'iran torni morte è sempre
dato è sempre da elogiare in questo
gioco rambo lodata questo di video
sempre pari al suo saluto che di sicuro
a lui
bene 10 diciamo così mette un gioco
sotto alzo qua sto per fare una miss
play sono convinto basta che mi esca
quello con cariche ho vinto teoricamente
l'unico che non dovevo uscire da questo
perché tutti gli altri andato bene
dovrei riuscire teoricamente a vincere
lo stesso però troviamoci uguale dovrei
storicamente riuscire lo stesso a
vincere però avevo b se avessi letto
bene stazione avrei vinto prima prova
per niente fa niente vacca che il mio
cervello dai ti prego fammi vincere che
avevo vinto ei portatori sono tutti
perché non servono file search però si è
rivelato un segreto quindi mio
ma potevo vincere lo stesso però mai in
far durare la partita autori più sono
troppi inter cure questo lo disse
montale marino non è male questa parte
sta molto meglio la perfetto la partenza
è giusta cosa fa il suo o meglio cosa mi
ha messo atleti magie e non è male
nobile sacrificio e non è ma che più o
meno la stessa cosa fin dalla luce
dorata evoca un con un saluto e un
servizio è morto in questa parka vacca
buonissima la sua la sua è pazzesca raga
allora adesso prendiamo un po di buoi e
direi di mettere tesi tela e di andare
in da a write
cosa mi ha messo pipistrello estremo del
fuoco in presentano le ricordo che è
successo qua vediamo che cosa diavolo ha
come segreto rabbia questo importante
anzitutto è questa qua non aver vinto
convinto era è stata molto più del
previsto
la partita va bene ragazzi allora la
partenza di questo è stato un po più
movimentata però teoricamente a dovrei
cavare dico così però vediamo bravo
mamma mia il gran giocata però ansa rai
che un po depistato la psiche
certo un po di bordello però sta
funzionando tutto per adesso è più o
meno fornisce il suo ritiro servirà così
cala cala madonna ti stai proprio
proteggendo comparato che casinò sta
facendo questo per tentare di vincerla
anatomia e stamane non mente ha detto di
conoscere power up in the face non è
male non è male signori non è male non è
male non è male questa carta mi ricorda
sempre un po mufasa non solo righe che
ruba fino a 3 d attacco e bla bla bla
bla bla questa non è male questa non è
ma cos'è questo di solito i servitori io
ti direi di levare fuori dalle palle
giocabili ma poi nel casino arabi a uno
dei cassetti grandi per tac
ma dài dài e dài e dài e ottima giocata
anche questa ragazzi ormai ex per taiz
finiamo le nostre tecniche lo zio
minorili squadra 8 le palle queste magie
di fare casino sì però preparatore
fisico come fai vai zio cigliano domani
e stato divertente ma dai ragazzi onde
evitare questo video vada all'infinito
perché devo ancora perdere due volte
perché finisca duello mi è piaciuto
molto
nel senso che mi sono trovato subito
bene quindi fichissimo ragazzi spero che
ci sia piaciuto quest'anno espansione di
hurst grazie la frizzante come sempre
fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate
senza prestiti iscrivetevi e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video e
ragazzi
[Musica]